opponents of chile's new proposed
constitution never dreamed they'd win
sunday's referendum by such a wide
margin
some toasted the victory
honked their horns convinced that the
charter would have fanned divisions and
instability
i think the majority of us want a new
constitution and that must be respected
but it has to be done properly with
capable people
supporters of the proposed text insist
it was progressive and cutting edge it
guaranteed gender parity social rights
to all allowed abortion and protection
of the environment
yet many others believe it went too far
for instance by recognizing chilean
indigenous groups as individual nations
some people even from the center left
that are voting reichasso or rejection
of the sex is because they fear
that this that the chile will be
dismembered somehow voting in this
referendum was mandatory but that's not
the only reason why this vote will
likely be remembered as the one with the
highest citizen participation in chilean
history so far it's an indication of
just how much chileans believe that a
new constitution has the possibility of
changing their lives for better or for
worse
humbled by the electoral defeat
left-wing president gabriele borrice
acknowledged that the proposal he'd
supported was not what the people wanted
i promise that i will do all i can
together with congress and members of
civil society to present a new
constitutional calendar using the
lessons of this process to deliver a new
text that will interpret the will of the
people
the referendum has dealt a strong blow
to the president whom many blame for a
rise in inflation and crime
people such as cecilia who voted against
the constitution
to be honest i did not read it
now the process starts all over again
prolonging uncertainty in a country that
needs social and economic change but
can't agree on how much
to see newman al jazeera santiago